مدخل مستشفى غزه الاوروبي في اقصى الجنوب
الشرقي لمحافظه خانيونس هذا المستشفى
يستقبل الجرحى والشهداء يوميا بفعل غراه
الاحتلال الاسرائيليه وكذلك يستقبل نازحين
ما بين الحين والاخر مع نزوح اهالي شمال
قطاع غزه الى هذه المنطقه كذلك المناطق
الشرقيه من المحافظه يعني ينزح المواطنون
باتجاه هذا المستشفى في هذه المنطقه
تحديدا هنا هو الحد الاقصى الذي يستطيع
المواطن ان يصل اليه باتجاه المستشفى لكن
في
الاجزاء الشماليه من هذا الشارع لا تواجد
لاي حركه سواء حركه مواطنين ا او حتى حركه
مركبات في هذا الشارع نظرا لان العمليه
العسكريه الاسرائيليه مستمره في هذه
المنطقه خاصه منطقه حي المناره الى الشمال
من الصوره وكذلك في الاجزاء اليمنى من
الصوره ايضا منطقه معن وامتداد هذه
المنطقه هو امتداد الضابطه الجمركيه حيث
اليات الاحتلال ما زالت تقوم باعمال
حفريات في هذه المنطقه على اكثر من صعيد
وتستمع في خلفيه الصوت الى اصوات
الاشتباكات التي تندلع بين الحين والاخر
بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه وكذلك قوات
الاحتلال اضافه الى اصوات الانفجارات التي
تقوم بين الحين والاخر قوات الاحتلال
باطلاق قذائفها المدفعيه باتجاه منازل
المواطنين وممتلكات المواطنين الوضع صعب
جدا طلق نار
كثير المدفعيه بتضرب كل دقيقه كل دقيقه
بتنزل
قذيفه الوضع ماساو كله ضرب قذايف وضرب
مدفعي والكوت بتضرب
وا منطقه الحديديه يعني منطقه خطيره جدا
جدا هذه الطيارات طيارات استطلاع يعني اي
واحد بيشوفوه في المنطقه هذه لانه المنطقه
هذه تم تحذيرها من قبل انه ممنوع حدا
يتواجد فيها فاي واحد بتشوفها بتطخ عليه
في الصوره ايضا الى الناحيه اليمنى هناك
تشاهدون السنه الدخان تتصاعد من منطقه معن
بعد ان قامت طائرات الاحتلال او دبابات
الاحتلال بقصف هدف معين في تلك المنطقه
ولم يتم تحديد هذا الهدف حتى هذه اللحظه
حركه المواطنين في هذه في هذه المنطقه
محدوده او معدومه تماما ويضطر المواطنون
لسلوك لسلوك طرق وشوارع في الاجزاء
الجنوبيه المؤديه الى مدينه رفع في حين ان
قبل تقريبا اسبوعين هذا الشارع كان مفتوح
امام حركه المواطنين ويتحرك المواطنون
بشكل اعتيادي في هذه المنطقه لكن مع
قيام اليات الاحتلال
بالتوغل اكثر في المناطق الجنوبيه
والشرقيه من محافظه خونس تحديدا في منطقه
حي المناره وكذلك منطقه معن اصبح التحرك
في هذه الشوارع يعني بالغ الصعوبه وينطوي
عليه خطوره بالغه على حياه
المواطنين لقناه الجزيره اسماعيل ابو عمر
خان يونس جنوب قطاع غزه